a new study showing Nevada schools are
the most poorly funded in the entire
country we thank you for joining us on 8
news now at 11 I'm Brian Loftus now this
is all according to data release this
week by the education Law Center Sasha
Loftus broke down that data spoke with
those behind the study and also a local
parent tonight Sasha joins us live from
CCSD headquarters now with more
Brian the parent I spoke with says the
results of this study were disappointing
but not surprising she said it's one of
the many reasons she's decided to avoid
our state's public school system
altogether
a full year commitment a parent of two
Lindsey Paoli says she's already decided
to keep her kids out of public school I
decided I was either going to send my
kids to a private school or have to
leave the city that I love she says it
was an easy decision because of what she
calls continued problems we do have a
very healthy economy we just choose not
to fund our public education system
Amanda Morgan executive director of
educate Nevada now shed some light on
our state's public school ranking of the
most poorly funded in the country
according to a study by the education
Law Center the 2022 making the grade
report examines money levels
distribution and effort and Nevada was
the only state to get an F on all three
spending about forty three hundred
dollars less per student than the rest
of the country virtually every County
with the exception of maybe a couple are
really struggling right now and have
been for many years Morgan believes a
solution lies with the legislature and
is pushing for lawmakers to make a
change in 2023. it's incredibly
frustrating but not at all surprising
unfortunately while Paoli says no matter
what she'll do what she can to keep her
family on the right track I gotta put
them first and make the right choice for
them
now this study also touched on the
impact covid-19 had on schools all
around the country financially now we
did reach out to CCSD and ccea for any
comment on this study and did not hear
back in time for this newscast reporting
live tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now